oh
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans cette école
d'ingénieurs les stars se sont elles
deux alpine installés de façon éphémère
dans cet auditorium de l'estaca les
voitures alpine franchement je suis
étonnée elle sont vachement belle elle
est magnifique des super belle ligne une
belle couleur biens a créé c'est la
fierté française que c'est ça fait
plaisir de voir des belles sportives
les deux véhicules ont été installés
dans le cadre d'une conférence sur
l'univers de la marque une première pour
l'école au programme l'histoire de
l'entreprise fondée en 1955 et sa
renaissance depuis 2015 l'objectif c'est
de susciter les vocations mais pas
seulement je pense que les étudiants qui
ont choisi la filière automobile à
l'estaca ce sont déjà des gens
passionnés et enthousiastes pour le
métier de l'autoroute pour les métiers
de l'automobile
pour nous ce qui est avant tout
principal moteur ses véritables monde de
partager notre passion pour alpines les
deux professionnels sont également allés
à la rencontre des étudiants pendant
près d'une heure pour partager leur
expérience dans le monde de l'automobile
et découvrir les différents projets de
l'école ça fait plaisir ça manque quand
on s'intéresse à l'école que ça une
renommée déjà et que du coup on voit que
l'école est présente dans tous les
milieux et cresta cas à une certaine
heure une certaine cote
ils sont du métier et c'est vrai que ça
fait rêver ça nous donne envie de
forcément de faire le même métier dans
les mêmes boîtes
ça nous donne un bel aperçu de notre
futur métier d'ingénieur sémalens vie de
de poursuivre juste ans jusqu'en
cinquième année l'histoire entre l'estac
à la marque alpine n'est peut-être pas
encore terminé de nouvelles conférences
pourraient être organisées dans les
prochaines années
au plus grand bonheur des étudiants